so before we dive in i want to tell you
a little story that happened on the way
into the studio this morning
i uh stopped to get there
already
go away
and try to bother you mr riley we just
want to ask you a few questions
i don't give interviews oh we're not
looking for an interview
give me one good reason why i should
talk to you i'm billy louis's daughter
that's a terrible reason for me to talk
to you
my name is samantha carpenter
i was attacked last night at the
hospital the night before that my sister
was stabbed seven times
i know you know what that's like
i'm just trying to protect my family
five minutes
that's all i'm asking
i'll give you two minutes
i'm missing a short awake bangs again
someone on stage and entertainment
weathers
weren't you two um
yeah
who's he oh this is richie my boyfriend
how long have you known him
six months did he know who your dad was
when you met
express any interest in woodsboro or the
ghostface killings what the hell are you
talking about your killer's obsessed
with the stab movies right
well
there's certain rules to surviving a
stab movie
believe me i know
rule number one
never trust the love interest
they seem sweet caring supportive then
welcome to act three where they're
trying to rip your head off i was with
sam in modesto when tara was attacked
and let me guess you were just in the
other room conveniently unaccounted for
when she was attacked at the hospital
okay do i have to take this from
elliot over here or what rule number two
the killer's motive
is always connected to something in the
past
i'm related to billy right but then why
kill that random vince guy that's for
you to figure out
rule number three and this is the most
important rule
the first victim always has a friend
group that the killer is a part of
does your sister have a close-knit group
of friends
yeah
she does
then look for the killer there
if you can find out why they're doing
this you can figure out who's next
so help us help us figure out who's
behind this oh you're kidding me i've
been stabbed nine times i've got
permanent nerve damage and a fun little
limp you think i want to do that again
you just said it always goes back to the
past right
so
if i'm in danger
that means you're in danger
come on
let's do this
together
[Music]
your time's up
jesus
yeah he's way more fun in the movies
okay uh what's next
the friends
thanks so much for that kevin coming up
after our local weather the pros and
cons of reuniting with old friends
ugh
hello
hey sid it's me
dewey
oh my god how long has it been
i'm just trying to get a run-in before i
take the girls to school how are you
i'm good really good how are you how's
mark i think i'll keep him
how are things in the sheriff's business
uh they're
they're fine but have you talked to gail
lately
no
not in a couple years
i know things didn't end well with you
guys but sid
it's happening again
what are you talking about some idiot in
a ghost face mask
three attacks so far one dead
something about this one just feels
different
are you okay
fine you know me
yeah
i do that's why i'm asking
i'm fine
i just
i just want you to be safe up there do
you have a gun
i'm sydney prescott of course i have a
gun
good that's good
scale now no she's my next call
but sid promise me no matter what you
hear what you say on the news
don't come here no offense to i have no
intention of ever setting foot in that
town again
good
dewey
whoever this killer's after i'm glad
they have you to protect them
you'll be safe okay
we'll do
it's good to hear your voice
you too sid
come on get it together
probably shouldn't have said that smiley
face
[Applause]
you